breaking users in the last few moments
day one of the satellite revolution our
first story this evening
that's an interesting a scene that is
developing full legislation won't be in
place until next year
welcome to the Sky News leaders debate
this is an election about Britain's
future
now that burgers readmit ins into the
world community Diana Princess of Wales
has died I'm about three miles into the
road to Pristina over the cost of an
border plane has crashed into the World
Trade Center by you're live on Sky News
right now wow what a sight a massive
earthquake has brought devastation to
countries around the Indian Ocean
they've been that reports of an
explosion outside Liverpool Street
Station where were you when America
picked a black man for president
from where I'm standing here on Clapham
Junction I cannot see one policeman at
all we're live on Sky News that
boardwalk is simply not there anymore
it's over here the total amount spent or
earned into it and in any given quarter
but that won't be what's making the
headlines tomorrow good morning this is
Sky News sunrise good afternoon we start
with some breaking news just want to
bring you the very latest we start
tonight with breaking news